you remember the first disturbing thing  you saw that made an impact on you yeah  there was a movie about Isadora Duncan  the ending is she's in the back of a  roadster and she's wearing this long  flowing scarf that's just hanging down  and then  they're driving around and then the  scarf gets caught in the wheel of the  Roadster and  strangles her to death I'm sure that one  of the reasons it made such an  impression is I was so thoroughly bored  by the movie up until that moment until  that happened all right  you know and so on the ride home so I'm  just full of questions about dying by  your scarf getting caught in the wheels  of a car yeah and it's like this major  concern all of a sudden I'm so afraid of  this and my mom says Quentin you have  nothing to worry about I would never  ever let you wear a long flowing scarf  in a convertible Roadster